I've sat there at reunions and final
parties when the whole cast has been
against me three times so I've never
shied away from it before and I'm not
sure I shouldn't Lisa Vanderpump saying
her piece before sneaking out of the
Real Housewives of Beverly Hills season
9 premiere party how do you feel about
seeing everybody here tonight
the early bird catches the world but she
avoided any run-ins with her co-stars it
doesn't surprise me
truly you know yeah it's very difficult
you know I care about both Lisa and Ken
and I never imagined it would get to
that point and it's unfortunate and I
hope that one day it can be resolved
this is a big shot to me it's so blatant
I've done nothing wrong
Kyle I swear on my children's life if I
did something wrong that doesn't mean
you wouldn't love me I'm not going to
say yes I did something if I didn't do
it I feel like I'm here to fight you
saying here to tell me I am a liar what
needs to happen for it to be resolved is
there any one thing that could kind of
magic fix it and see the person which is
why I actually didn't know she had left
so I thought oh that's nice I hope and
say hi but she's already left so not
tonight not tonight
Julie hopefully okay I love you how can
you say you loved me
all right you don't you know I'm an easy
easy girl to repair things with you know
it just takes an apology or a
conversations that that's true and
honest and real and to people that want
to you know and I'm always up for trying
to repair something always I mean I I'm
not exactly calling her to do it but you
know you have to also tune in and see
you know see the season because there's
a lot that happened and I think having
this conversation now it's difficult to
answer those questions when you haven't
seen it
[Music]